il se confirme de plus en plus que le
sort de cette centrale est devenu l'un
des principaux enjeux de cette guerre
oui tout à fait filmer pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que c'est
l'une des plus grosses si ce n'est la
plus puissante centrale nucléaire
d'europe elle assure jusqu'à 20% de
l'électricité ukrainienne six réacteurs
depuis la fermeture de la centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl donc elle est
très important de très stratégique pour
les ukrainiens mais aussi pour les
forces russes qu'ils occupent depuis
plusieurs mois elle est toujours sous
contrôle des autorités ukrainiennes mais
qui est bien répondre aux ordres des
forces armées russes qu'ils occupent
depuis plusieurs mois elle a été le
théâtre de nombreuses frappes le 5 août
dernier cela entraîné la fermeture de
l'un des réacteurs et puis il ya eu une
dizaine de frappes il y a quelques jours
qui a entraîné la la la la réunion en
urgence du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
qui exige qu'ils demandent que des
observateurs internationaux de l'aiea
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique puissent venir constater et et
comprendre en fait qui sont à l'origine
de ces frappes car comme d'habitude et
bien les russes et les ukrainiens se
renvoie cette responsabilité accusant
l'un et l'autre d'être complètement
irresponsables puisque une catastrophe
nucléaire ne poserait pas seulement
problème évidemment à l'ukraine ni à
l'homme et au monde entier alors en
l'absence de ces observateurs
internationaux il est extrêmement
compliqué de savoir ce qu'il s'y passe
réellement toujours est il que la
centrale nucléaire de zappos lydia est
la cible de nombreuses frappes depuis
quelques jours qu'en est il par ailleurs
des combats dans le reste de leur peine
ecoutez-la concentre l'attention se
concentre essentiellement sur l'est le
dombass et le sud de l'ukraine heures
sur l'est de l'ukraine et bien en ce
moment il ya une ville qui suscite un
petit peu à la tension c'est la ville de
barr mouthe qui est un tout petit peu
plus au sud de ce lot viande et crame à
tort les russes qui approche très
lentement de cette ville qui serait si
elle était prise plus symbolique que
stratégique le but c'était pour eux de
prendre aussi rapidement surveillance
quelques rames à tort ce que et bien
d'autres villes d'udon basse et en fait
ça n'est pas le cas a selon les
renseignements britanniques mais aussi
selon washington est également les
forces armées ukrainiennes ce qu'ils
pensaient pouvoir être repris assez
rapidement par la russe finalement ne
sera pas en tout cas occupé avant le
printemps prochain
il se trouve que en réalité la stratégie
ukrainienne si l'on comprend bien ce qui
se passe sur sur le territoire c'est de
se concentrer en tout cas en terme de
communication sur cette contre offensive
dans le sud est de forcer la russie à
descendre des hommes depuis l'ambassade
vers le sud pour les démobilisés un
petit peu du côté du dombass pourquoi
parce que ça fait plusieurs semaines que
vladimir weiss qui annonce cette
contre-offensive vers résonne dans le
sud donc ces territoires occupés par la
russie les renseignements britanniques
ont confirmé hier la quasi destruction
de deux ponts extrêmement stratégique le
pont d'antonov cas et le pont de caroff
qu'à ses deux ponts sont quasiment
inutilisable aujourd'hui or sans ces
ponts et bien les l'armée russe qui
occupe la partie ouest du nieppe de
cette rivière qui est parfois très large
ne peut pas se recharger en munitions
c'est donc de ce sont donc des ponts
très stratégique qui annonce peut-être
une réelle contre offensive de la part
des ukrainiens